the current F1 Champion just proved that
he's no different than any of us Gamers
I think I'm gonna uninstall the game
that's nice Max verstappen the back to
back Formula One World Champion was
taking part in an online race during the
off season the 24-hour Le Mans virtual
race but over 18 hours into the race
verstappen and his team experienced
something very familiar to every gamer
he disconnected while in first place
they call it uh it's amazingly bad luck
well this is just incompetence what
happened next was well some good old
gamer rage Max retired from the race
called the event a clown show and then
uninstalled the game and I really hope
everyone installs the game this guy who
legit hangs out with the hottest dudes
racing the fastest cars actually just
Rage Quit from an online tournament but
honestly I'd probably react a lot worse
if me and my team had been practicing
for months grinded for 18 hours all for
nothing I'm just happy to know Max
verstappen is one of us but if clogged
up memory is causing your games to crash
download Opera GX today so that never
happens again